欢迎收看最佛心幽默的财经节目
理财达人秀
我是李兆华
好终于揭晓了
怎么样呢
9月升息一马
这个应该叫做预期中
那现在看来委员们的投票
年底前应该会再升一马
似乎也没有太离谱
昨天晚上美股费半
还等不及开奖
已经先涨了
说实话这段时间大家太闷了
而今天的台股盘中
一度也是气势如虹
上涨超过1000点
但是可能涨着涨着
大家会觉得
毕竟还是有一些问题
没有完全解决
所以今天的台股
留了一个长长的上影线
贵满甚至中场是翻黑的
似乎涨一半
锅盖拿起来一半
那剩下一半我们该怎么看呢
还有哪一些难关要度过
因为毕竟不止美国升息
现在欧洲亚洲升息风
都在吹起来
有没有可能变成一个
升息环境
而AI的成长能否抵抗
这就很重要哦
所以我们必须回归到产业面
今天的来宾要好好的跟您聊
善用工具懂得产业
如果明年的成长性
比今年还要高
那就非常值得期待
可以抵御高的利率环境
先来欢迎今天的三位来宾
第一位是我们的
报价天王心腹哥
好天王驾到要来聊
到底联准会这个决策会议
讲了些什么呢
到年底前可能还会有一次的升息机会
市场到底要担心还是不要担心
但媳妇哥说有一个事情是铁打的事实
其中选举要来了
选举后尤其第四季
涨势特别凌厉
这个历史不容易改变
而且做梦行情也随即要展开
台股基本面也很好
今天帮您点名华邦店出手咯
买下银飞铃的No Fresh厂
到底记忆拼图的下一步
怎么要来观看
CPU依旧是盘中的强势股
美股的CPU也大涨
他认为看上游是最稳的
等一下来分享
好第二位是我们的黄金右下角
选股教练维泰
维泰每次来都要帮我们救个火
这个礼拜天天都有火
不是大力光就是建策跟围影
今天轮到谁
CCL被打下去连帽杀到跌停板翻不上来
原因也是CPU
说普及后不需要用到高规格的CCL
到底事情是如何
会不会是错杀
等一下围态好好跟您聊
当然纵观盘面
其实回到产业的话
2奈米是我们台积电
现在最在行的订单满手
所以最便宜的黄金右下角
就在封测跟设备
等一下来跟您聊了
第三位是我们的ETF教父
存股教父古瑜
古瑜来到现场
要跟大家讲一个事情
这个升息风不只在美国
可能亚洲欧洲都会有
但是如果今天美元走强的话
对于我们电子股的外销
无疑又是一个强心针
他还是非常有信心
在这样的底气下
观众问了一个很犀利的问题
为什么同样一个经理人
手上有主动ETF跟主动基金
却是基金的绩效比较好
等一下谷鱼独家解惑
现在要进场
是不是选基金
当然有一个好的平台
是一个制胜关键
好 首先有请幸福哥
好 幸福哥台股 美股都在这边等
像前两天都窒息量了
就是等升息的消息
但今天上引线大概有500点
涨一半而已
你认为其中选举之后
应该会再去涨
再来华邦店买了英飞林的厂
怎么看
CPU你觉得上游很有戏
来 我们来看一下
那当然联准会这一次升息
算是市场之前就有预测到
因为在前几天
这个升息的几率就已经将近
有9成
那投票的結果呢
是12票全數通過
那目標利率呢
調高一碼來到3.75%到4%
不過呢
他們也針對
今年一些通膨的數據
包括像是這個PCE
核心PCE有做了一個調升
不過呢
明年整體的通膨
會稍微下來一點
變這個2.3%
會降下來
那他們認為
大概通膨要到2029年才會看到2%的聯準會的一個目標值我們知道其實這兩年兩年或說這兩三年來AI帶動全球的經濟是有一波蠻大的一個成長
特別是科技業
所以從GDP
你可以發現
這是9月的預估值
紅色的
是比6月還要來的高
然後失業率也是下降的
這個都是好事
但是從通膨數據PCE來看的話
其實它也是在增加
就代表說
其實市場有一點點
兩方在拉鋸
就是說呢
雖然通膨高
所以我們要升息
但是呢
景氣很好
這也是不爭的一個事實
所以就看
哪一方在這個裡面呢
它的一個角色會扮演比較重
這也是左右聯準會的一個決議
那當然因為
9月開始升一馬之後
大家比較關心
今年還不會再升
照目前來看的話
最新的一個數據
大概有機會呢
12月會再升一馬
是
那9月這一次已經結束了嘛
10月還會再開始會
然後11月沒有 12月會
所以還有兩次
那兩次裡面呢
年底現在預估啦
還有機會再升一馬
當然這不是絕對的
只是目前的預估值
那降息的話
明年可能機率比較低啦
那如果通膨再升高
當然有機會再升息
那中位數目前顯示
大概維持利率不變
所以這個是
目前聯準會的一個態度
那至於說呢
這個會影響到什麼
為什麼大家一直在講說
好像通膨很高
或者說這個
只要升息
哇 這個股市就會崩盤
那我認為
其實要分兩個角度來講
就是說當年度到底景氣是好還是不好
如果景氣好
升息可能兩方就會有一點在拉扯
但是如果像2022年那一年也是升息
不過企業獲利大幅度衰退
那一定是空頭市場
那我們來看一個表
這邊有外資機構去統計
黃色這個是標普500指數
未來一年的EPS預估
你可以很明顯的發現
它的這個獲利的成長是明顯大於
標普500指數的成長
就代表其实基本面是好的
除了刚刚我们讲的这个升息之外
其实9月还有一个历史因素
我们可以统计大家看
比较黑的偏深色
这个是1960到2026
你可以发现是跌的
是跌的
然后2006到2026
就是近20年也是跌的
是12个月里面
9月其实通常表现最差
不过大家也不要担心
9月过完之后呢
10月11月特别是11月
是每年里面表现最好的
所以我们预估
搭配美国的其中选举
那其實第四季我個人認為是
台股或美股呢
是有機會再往上走
特別是台股的部分
有機會再來挑戰
這歷史新高
那至於說呢
美國的期中選舉也蠻妙的
他之前都會先回黨
因為也是不確定性因素
不過呢選完之後呢
他們有去統計
一樣從1962年到2022年
每四年一次的這個期中選舉
其實選完之後
一年平均漲幅大概有14%
14%
所以代表說其實
越接近這個期中選舉之前
如果有出現像
這個禮拜的
這個禮拜一禮拜二那種擊殺
那是不是反而你是要逆向去思考
是不是有機會先去進場
慢慢做布局
那大盤的部分呢
今天呢有攻上去
這個短線的反壓月線
不過比較可惜是因為
早盤漲幅有點大
再加上今天有一些
市場的這個鬼故事
那把一些中小型的股
或一些之前熱門的股票
什麼CCLR這些壓下來
所以呢導致漲幅收斂
不過整體來看
目前还是月季线都还是往上走
我认为其实架构还是比较偏
正向是没有什么太大的改变
那当然我们观察这个AI
还有一个重要的数据
我觉得大家也可以参考
就是AI每个GPU它的租赁价格
租赁价格
不是说每个公司都像Meta
像微软像AWS
他们钱多多
可以自己买设备来盖资料中心
很多中小型企业我需要AI
但是我是用租的就好
我不用自己花那么多点去盖
那你可以發現它的租賃價格
其實基本上都還是往上
其實代表說
其實市場對AI的需求還滿強的
那至於說台積電的部分
我認為它今年也會再創新高
也會再創新高
那我們上次有講過
台積電今年大概100塊
明年大概130到150
130到150
所以從這樣來看的話
其實即便你用最保守的130去估
其實現在台積電今天的收盤價大概在2425其實它本利比PE本利比也是不到20倍就代表說其實我認為20倍以下的台積電不算貴不算貴那你如果去照實反映這個
20倍的本益比的話
其實它一定會過前面的高點
那只要台積電過高
台股就有機會過高
好 真的是一定對不對
我都敢這樣講了
因為佔四成嘛
台積電比重佔台股四成
所以台積電過高
台股應該就過高了
這是一個
好 那至於記憶體的部分是這樣
今天有大事
今天也震盪很大
那一個大新聞是
華邦電用300多億收購了
Infilling的No Flash
那其實No Flash算是
記憶體裡面一個算是
比較小眾的市場
它需求是一定有的
但是其實它跟低潤
或跟Net比
它的佔比是比較低
那收購之後它會變成是
一個在產品線
擴展得更完整的一個情況
那No Flash的一個市佔率
會高達34%
它會穩坐龍頭
所以目前來看的話
華邦店透過這樣的一個策略
去讓它的產品性更完整
我覺得對於它搭建整個公司的護城河
是有更加強的效果
所以我認為這個收購案目前看起來
我認為是
當然後面的企業整合
還有怎麼樣把這個收賓進來的企業
做更進一步的融進華邦店的文化
我覺得這是一個關鍵
那記憶體最近大家可以發現很難做
一下漲一下跌 一下漲一下跌
那主要幾個原因
第一個我們來看一下這個DRAM
左邊這是DRAM的報價
你可以發現DRAM的報價普遍
大概還是慢慢慢慢往上爬
但是這邊有NAT跟DRAM指數
你可以發現深色這個NAT指數
最近就沒什麼動了
是很平的
所以如果大家再看最近為什麼
DRAM系列像南亞科華邦店相對比較強
那NAT系列的股價就比較弱
原因就是因為DRAM的這個報價
目前是稍微比較呈現焦灼
那還有一個關鍵就是合約價的部分
合約價的話
我們知道今年上半年漲很多
甚至到第二季
YOY有五成到六成
可是到第三季就開始會收斂了
大概13%到18%
那到第四季大概會到5%左右
所以就代表說
像上半年大家那種
可能整個記憶體一買
直接後面30% 50%漲一倍
可能下半年會很難複製
會比較變成是高低檔震盪
高低檔震盪 為什麼
因為大家預期
你這個未來
如果合約價漲不收斂的話
你那個獲利的暴衝期
就會開始放緩
絕對數字還會增加
但是那個暴衝的一個成長性
會開始變慢
那這時候大家就會去找什麼
找更有機會的
暴衝性更好
所以我認為最近機體的部分
雖然我們看這個營收
很多都什麼500% 600% 300%的一大堆
不過最近高漲震盪也是很劇烈
那我們是認為說
比較偏DRAM的這個區塊
華邦電跟納雅科
會是目前比較好的一個挑選
因為畢竟我們剛剛看它的報價
還在往上走
會是比較具有優勢一點
那至於股價的部分我們來看一下
華方電當然前幾天呢
還有跌破月季線
基礎面是比較弱的
可是大家可以發現
最近回跌只要是基本面還不錯
其實跌的時候基本上量都是縮的
好 期瘦了
那反倒是在攻
像今天攻雖然有點可惜
月季線這兩個大反壓沒有一次攻過
不過呢其實量反的是
稍微有比前兩天大
所以它比較關鍵就是前面這個
比較密集這兩三個
比較密集的套牢區
能不能夠有效的去做突破
那也順勢的站回月季線之上
我覺得是接下來
這個股價轉強的關鍵
不過相對
南亞科已經接近高點來講
他目前大概還在
比較偏半山藥的位置
這是一個
那南亞科是這一波有先過高的
不過過高之後
我記得我們上次有來講
就是你看這個美光
或者說像海力士等等
他們還沒過高
你南亞科過高之後
其實他不可能一直衝
所以要拉回到這個月季線左右
不過因為他其實獲利
現在單月大概都有七到八塊
那很多現在的產能都被長約鎖定
我們就先拿今年的獲利做個預估
其實它明年假設都可以保持這樣的數據的話
大概80到100的EPS沒有什麼太大
所以說它其實下檔會有保物
只要回跌到重要的均線支撐
其實它股價就會彈
但是你一看漲追或看創新號去追
可能它會馬上給你殺回來
所以我覺得記憶體的操作就我剛剛前面講因為它那個報價的一個爆衝期已經過了你不要想說就像第二季一樣哇 200買突然漲到500或者說你現在500買
以後會漲到1,000 2,000
我覺得不會
它會變成在高檔來回震盪
有擊殺你買 上去
那有獲利你來回操作
這樣獲利會比你之前
長包的模式會比較好一點
這是記憶體
星木哥之前有教我們
反而到了重要的均線
下跌的時候
才是一個買的時候對不對
對
千萬不要用追的
這個有教過我們操作的邏輯
還有華邦店竟然變成
NFlish的世界龍頭
對望宏會有影響嗎
我認為因為其實
現在記憶體的產能
還是蠻缺的
所以其實
對於望宏來說的話
我認為影響不是特別大
主要還是因為
Netflix最近的報價
稍微比較弱勢一點
所以它的股價
目前整理的時間
可能會拉得比較長一點
好 是個別的問題
因為很多人也很關心望宏
OK 好
那我觉得比较值得关心的
就是大盘现在还没创高
但是领先创高的族群里面
很多党其实都跟CPU细光子相关
就我刚前面讲的
现在资金会去找寻
下一个具有爆炸性成长的产业
那目前看起来CPU似乎是大家
这个认同度比较高的
那你可以发现
这个是CPU它的渗透率
你可以发现这两年
2025、2026
虽然题材之前吵了很久
可是你会发现其实这个
滲透率连1%都没有
明年开始变2%
变7% 变20%到30%
所以几乎是从零开始
所以它这个爆发力就会特别强
所以为什么资金
很多会跑到这个锡光子相关的
让它的股价领先大盘创高
原因就在这里
好
那CPU的从上中下游来看的话
当然很多最上游厂商
都是国外的厂商
像什么流民光学这些
对那台湾的话
我们先简单
把它做一个上中下游的区分
那目前比较缺的
其实是在偏上游的
零化银的累晶
或者说它相关的一些产品
那像联雅全新
IET这个就比较偏上游的累晶
那还有这做雷射代工的这些
那大家都可以看
还有像做组装的
一些光模组的组装
等等这些
大家可以稍微去做一个参考
近期今天的股价表现
还有它前八个月的
营收的一个年增率
今天很多也是开高走低
今天中小型都是这样子
就我刚刚前面讲到
很多的CPU或光通信相关
其实他们都已经过了前一波的高点
而且他们的好处是
其实5月6月台股大涨的时候
其实他们几乎都在盘跌
他们那前一波是完全没涨到
也就是说他们之前整理的时间
是比目前很多
在第二期创新高的个股
大概多了两三个月整理
刚好最近不管台积电或辉达
都有讲说
今年整個CPU
已經開始要陸續順利量產了
所以你可以發現
股價為什麼會領先過高
一定有它的原因
因為之前本來三四月
大家說可能會延遲
所以股價就
哇 慢慢回跌下來
可是通過這樣子的一個
利空洗禮之後
反倒是大廠出來背書
股價就上來
當然因為最近盤勢
我們認為還是震盪比較大
所以我們常常講
你不要連漲才追
比如說第一根或許要有機會
兩天之後還漲
可是你去追到第三根
那可能就给你洗盘
甚至今天创新高你盘中去追
他盘中就要涨停
涨停 创新高
感觉气势如何
对啊 如果你想说
创新高了特动进去追
哇 今天洗刷一下
这最后只涨了不到5%
这个震荡会非常大
那连压也是啊
他也是过高之后
马上可以拉回
但他回档过了
对 有回档过了
所以今天呢
因为整个CPU
也是有点开高走低
所以他被带下来
所以你看你这边拉一条横线
他就过了之前
两个前面套下去之后
股價有稍微再創高
但是馬上就拉回來
不過我認為短期之內
應該會在這個重要的均線這邊
來回去做一個震盪
那我是認為說
目前整個CPU 細光子
在成長動能這麼強的情況之下
如果未來台股要創高
這個族群呢
應該相對來說
還是市場關注的焦點
今天不管記憶體或者是CPU
其實幸福哥都選偏上游的對不對
對 目前看起來
上游的狀況是會比較明確一點
而且也可以發現
他們的營收成長動能
確實是比較高一些的
好 這邊非常謝謝
包教天王幸福哥
謝謝